ma petite fille a disparu monsieur
je veux qu'on me le ramène au plus vite
et vous monsieur vous monsieur
vous êtes d'après ce qu'on m'a dit
l'homme de la situation
chaque bras est équipé d'un dispositif
explosif votre pantalon est également
équipés d'explosifs
sérieux
là de l'endroit où nous nous tenons ce
mode jeu une portion de route où règne
le mar
c'est quoi ça au bout de cinq jours et
si vous n'êtes toujours pas revenue avec
bérénice
vous avez compris l'idée je crois que
dieu vous garde
nous sommes ghost landes ici mon ami
tr 106 sièges
ce n'est pas nous qui la retenaient
captifs
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux jours
et elle manque toujours à l'appel
[Musique]
comment je fais pour monsieur est ici
il devait succomber à la
à
ans
allez lens
je suis
north mois
radioactu
personne ne s'échappe du ghost en
personne
c'est plus prisonnière
[Musique]